[Music]
your gums like what maybe an hour and a
half ago so we just have to know the
next thing up third and I like to hook
up my beans and rice and my chilaquiles
with sour cream everywhere
I loved it when I was ordered filet and
guys a pozole hack it's not really happy
but the way I like to enjoy my post it
into my aunt taught me not really young
if you get your bullet put all eggs and
then you scoop up some sour cream and
then you put a whole bunch of lime on it
and then you get a tostada and then you
smear sour cream on the cassava and then
you put laminate and then you sprinkle
some salt and then you eat that with
your posole it's so unhealthy with so
delicious pozole a pose elite that's
good one right is it daddy right mmm hey
that's your first burrito ever huh now I
have read up but I used to have sardines
and I guess he took out the beans
we took out all that that's not much of
a reader though your breed only at the
size of mine and I got three over here
to the same burrito and it
ended up being like twice the size that
we could I'm sorry to get full you're
getting booked when you drink all this
I'm thirsty
dripping water oh yeah I should see it
[Music]
versus ceviche though yeah yeah so this
place how are they pulling ceviche whew
- is $7.00 but it looks like cooked
shrimp that doesn't look like there's
shrimp fish and octopus in here okay
let's see if they made it achieve your
way or the real boy I'm cooking with the
lime lemon or cooking it like pre
boiling it how do you how do you know
but like how can you tell does it line
crunch it you can taste it both cooked
by the line you would taste it see
sometimes you can boil I said octopus
what do you think no it's not as lime
use it should be yeah I think I should
cheer away this looks like it's cooked
[Music]
just give me one no damn it
I need limes for the ceviche and the
fossil eggs I thought though there was
supposed to be
that's five bags and I'm just gonna I'm
gonna miss out on the linemen my boss my
legs you don't have any lives here oh
[Music]
nice you got it yeah nice it's not a
record we can record gameplay videos
nice now we could play games and then
you guys could see us play oh yeah let's
call the L ghetto oh yeah yeah I don't
know I hope it comes with instructions
and if it doesn't we'll figure it out
our YouTube video yep YouTube to the
product well YouTube the instruction
listen you guys should watch me play
Minecraft you playing Minecraft right
now why can't you just point a camera at
the screen you could you could Chris
Burke we're yeah you can get the audio
of the game better and then like yeah if
I did this there's a glare yeah so and
Isaac before we get started though what
what are what are like the most popular
game play games Oh
minecraft I do here for tonight in very
popular and it's pretty much it at least
what I know and then some other people
play different games like random games
so the games that you play you want to
make even play features for them yeah I
also have games on my switch like super
mario party mario kart oh I love
overcooks
that is one of my favorite family
pastime you guys you know it's one of my
favorite games that you recently have is
cuphead oh but I haven't played it
enough to get good at hit but a little
bit that I have played on like thing
this game is hard but I absolutely like
ridiculously like it's hard to explain
how much I love the animation or
whatever you call it like the graphics
and the music that they use the music is
I'm like I love this game I was actually
listening to the soundtrack in my car
because I'm like this music is awesome I
love it cuz it's like really old timey
and like old cartoons and stuff and like
a 2d kind of stuff like jazzy yeah I
love love love love love all that like
the 2d animation and like the old Disney
movies where they have more jazz for
music my favorite like my ultimate most
favorite thing ever
so cuphead is like it ranks up there for
me I just haven't had the chance to
actually play and get good at the game i
get frustrated with cuphead i get angry
that's what is it such a good game like
no wonder it's so popular because if it
was easy to known
I would it makes me happy to win cool
you ready to install this yeah go and do
the honors and open it yeah oh man the
cardboard is very smooth no yeah yeah
Lucy mmm very smooth name the packaging
for this is crazy Pino makes you feel
like you just got like a whole new game
console I know it's just a recording
device you might mean that and you're so
smart now I think when did you get so
I'm reading it from here but still like
that's cool you went from like when I
first met you you're the kid that
couldn't read the Lego instructions and
needed me to help you with all the Legos
and stuff me and mommy would build all
of it for you now you're like yeah dad
just do this just missing we got that
got to run yeah we built I go alright
saw you bug in the Elgato
out peanut I don't care about Legos
right now oh yeah I also put this
sticker right here right now cool reppin
it roll it roll it roll it roll it
alright we have I like how you're like
you know what to do at the YouTube game
room so what's your sign in like how do
you like say hi and stuff like what do
they usually do um oh you do your thing
alright so alright alright alright so
we're playing halo Master Chief
collection and we will be having a great
time I know it's crazy though is you're
actually better at Mila's and I am No
yeah you had that kid god mode ability
where like you're just you just start
playing
you figure out the controls faster than
I actually forgot how to play it that we
learn it I'm just little slow you
learned the maps the way faster than I
do
yeah the graphics are very halo one yeah
but then I have played this one before I
don't like this one as much it's all
telling myself that I could do it so
scared what happened did you burn
yourself no you kept on shooting what is
this what is this way over what is that
I don't know if I like the flames are
you just test it out I think there is
actually pretty good this you need to go
closer just like using the swords and
this blow up can I heat up the grenades
and make it blow up mr. radish your job
I'll wait for you here
come find me Oh oh my goodness died so
close we got two canisters I still
haven't figured out how to navigate this
map yet
oh alright guy again no I die let
yourself okay
[Music]
wrong way
I have a shield you'd shoot my grenades
never tell you know I need a psycho
scared are you know how do you figure
this stuff out so fast oh I'm right
behind you man I'm still burning oh this
thing eats you while you're still
burning okay good thing for help thanks
everywhere oh my god this map is
annoying now I know who you are I don't
like the way that sounds it makes me
feel vulnerable
[Music]
no shotgun versus shotgun Brian up when
I used to play this game with my brother
we will sometimes have matches where
we're only allowed to hit each other
[ __ ] about there and it's so fun
I need a health pack did you pick me no
show you though yeah thank you
let's have a rocket launcher battle
this is so intense who killed who I shot
to know I can face it I can not shot
faster than I hit the rocket launcher is
kind of that makes me nervous because
they can't really see anything the
rocket launcher makes me nervous because
I can't see half the screen when I have
it I keep going into circles I keep
going to the same rooms every time I'm
like I'm go to a new room now it's the
same one over and over and over
[Music]
don't know why I'd take my shotgun
[Music]
they don't happen the timer
yeah I in first place with 19 kills 14
kills
yeah
[Music]
[Music]